das ist wirklich extrem spannend so ein
objekt wurde noch nie absolut noch nie
in unserem sonnensystem gesichtet es ist
extrem schnell kommt wahrscheinlich aus
den tiefen des alls und durchquert in
diesen tagen unser sonnensystem das
objekt ist so neu dass es in der
astrophysik eine kategorie für die
bezeichnung gibt woher es kommt was das
sensor zähler an dem objekt ist und
wohin es fliegt jetzt entwicklung
science fiction herzlich willkommen
weltpremiere bei pixum wenn alles
korrekt ist was jetzt beobachtet wurde
dann haben wir nicht mehr und nicht
weniger als den ersten beobachteten
durchflug eines interstellaren objektes
durch unser sonnensystem absolut
bemerkenswert ist schon mal woher es
kommt es kommt nämlich von oben am 2
september tauchte es senkrecht zu den
umlaufbahnen der planeten in unserem
sonnensystem zwischen sonne und merkur
bahn ein die kavitation der sonne lenkte
das objekt dann unterhalb der sonne in
richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der
erdumlaufbahn am 14 oktober an der erde
vorbei flog inzwischen ist das objekt
durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder
über die planeten hinaus geschossen
worden
ein solches objekt ist absolut nicht
vorherzusagen und entdeckt werden kann
es auch erst wenn es uns schon sehr nahe
ist als erster staat assam achtzehnter
oktober 2017 das 1,8 meter teleskop an
stars 1 auf dabei insel maui und dann
ergaben die bahn berechnungen des
objektes sehr schnell dass es nicht von
dieser welt also nicht von einem anderen
planeten hier im sonnensystem und
überhaupt nicht aus unserem sonnensystem
stammte anhand von richtung und
geschwindigkeit konnte schnell errechnet
werden dass es eben senkrecht in unser
sonnensystem geflogen war
es kam aus dem sternbild leier der
ursprung liegt nicht unweit des haupt
sterns vega wie schwer solche objekte zu
entdecken sind zeigt dass es nicht
entdeckt wurde als es am dichtesten an
der erde vorbei flog sondern auch schon
sich wieder entfernte mit ein grund
dürfte die geringe größe mit einem
durchmesser von rund 160 metern und die
hohe geschwindigkeit von 26 kilometern
pro sekunde also knapp
100.000 kilometer pro stunde wenn die
berechnungen jetzt präzisiert werden und
sich die bisherigen daten bestätigen ist
die sensation komplett es ist dann das
erste interstellare objekt dass wir beim
durchflug durch unser sonnensystem
entdeckt haben und wir werden es nie
wieder sehen während asteroiden ja wie
die planeten kreise um die sonne ziehen
und immer wieder kommt wird das bei
diesem objekt anders sein es fliegt nach
der umlenkung durch die sonne jetzt
wieder auf nimmerwiedersehen in den
interstellaren raum bis es wieder auf
gestirne trifft dieses umdenken noch
trägt es übrigens den namen a 2000 17
uhr 1a steht dabei für assault das wäre
aber kein interstellare objekt der name
muss also noch geändert werden ja wie
nur was sind eure ideen schreibt sie die
kommentare
wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den genau auf die
glocke denn nur dann verpasste er auch
kein video hier geht es weiter mit also
jeden bedrohen die erde jederzeit ja und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran